[Music]
plan is dangerous everything we do is
dangerous this rescue gonna be the
toughest thing you ever done I must say
I'm excited to see this season but I
heard that they tease you as a Wonder
Woman we're pregnant while filming this
second season we started shooting when I
was seven half months pregnant and how
did you manage that
I have no idea you know I had an amazing
supportive team my midwife was on said
my husband you know but we trekked
through man you know and underground is
not a very easy show even if you're not
pregnant
you know the stunts the conditions
working in the field but you know they
pushed me beyond my limits this season
and I just felt so blessed to be able to
do what I love Wow growing this
beautiful human being inside of it how
have you been adjusting some other hood
it is you know comes natural to me it
really does but it's amazing I feel like
I'm seeing the world through new eyes
you know watching him just you know be
so curious and learn everything for the
first time it it's a love you will never
know you know I mean until you
experience I've never known a love like
this before I've got a gush about you
and your husband the fact that you guys
did take a moment to have date night
during the award season and it was
incredible to see that how is he
adjusting to being a new daddy
he isn't incredible dad you know even
when I was pregnant he would talk to my
belly all the time and he just loved
Hunter so much he reads them every night
and like
you know they have their own amazing
bond so any advice from John since he's
doing the show any parenting advice from
him let Luna is stunning
so you know I think they've got they've
got it going on
whatever they're doing is right